estoy a punto de hacer una de las cosas
que menos me gusta hacer a mano lo cual
es invertir una matriz de 3 x 3 y bueno
lo único peor que invertir una matriz de
3 por 3 a mano es invertir una matriz de
4x4 o invertir una matriz de 5 por 5
también a menos que bueno es súper útil
hacerlo y hay que saber hacerlo porque
con eso puedes resolver sistemas de
ecuaciones entre otras cosas y hay que
hacerlo por lo menos alguna vez en la
vida pero lo feo es que es muchísima
talacha muchísimas cuentas y lo más
probable es que me equivoque sin darme
cuenta a la hora de hacer una resta o
algo así pero bueno realmente tenemos
que hacerlo a mano para entender bien
qué es lo que está pasando así es que
vamos y bueno lo primero que vamos a
hacer es sacar la matriz de menores que
hay matriz de menores
y lo voy a hacer lo más grande posible
para tener mucho espacio para sacar esta
matriz de menores lo que tenemos que
hacer es tomar una entrada de nuestra
matriz de 3 x 3 que queremos invertir
esta matriz y vamos a tachar esta
columna y esta fila que son la columna y
la fila en la que se encuentra nuestra
entrada y a lo que nos deja osea esta
matriz de aquí que no siempre se ve tan
bonita a veces está toda esparcida a lo
largo de esta matriz a estos cuatro
valores que nos deja le vamos a sacar el
determinante y esa es la menor de esta
matriz en esta entrada aunque hay
entonces vamos a reemplazar la entrada
que escogimos por la menor de esa matriz
con respecto a esa entrada que hay
entonces como escogimos esta entrada lo
que vamos a hacer es sacar el terminante
de lo que nos queda de tachar esta
columna y esta fila ok o sea este
determinante
que es el determinante 11
y ahora vamos con esta otra entrada lo
que hacemos es tachar la columna y la
fila en la que se encuentra y nos deja
esta matriz de 23 15 y sacamos el
determinante esa es la menor y
sustituimos esta entrada por el
determinante de la matriz que nos queda
a la hora de quitar estas entradas ok
entonces sustituimos esta entrada por el
determinante de 2 315 y ahora queremos
encontrar esta entrada que es la
correspondiente a esta entrada
así es que tú dime que tenemos que poner
aquí
ya listo ok quitamos esta columna y
quitamos esta fila y lo que nos queda es
la matriz 2 3 14 así es que sacamos su
determinante y eso va en esta entrada 23
14 muy bien vayamos a la siguiente
entrada aquí que es lo que tiene que ir
pues está echamos esta fila y esta
columna y nos queda simplemente el
determinante menos 2 245 determinante de
menos 2 245 a ver a ver qué es lo que
tiene que irene esta entrada
pues otra vez está echando esta columna
y esta fila nos queda el determinante de
menos 1 2 3 y 5 - 1 2 3 y 5
y ahora nos toca sacar el de esta
entrada o sea te echamos esta columna y
esta fila y nos queda el determinante de
menos uno menos 2 3 y 4 - 1 - 2 3 y 4
muy bien ya llevamos dos terceras partes
ahora saquemos este bueno se parecen
mucho este color pero te juro que estoy
tratando de no repetir colores así es
que como se parece tanto mejor no
ponemos ese y ponemos este
entonces tachamos esta columna y este
renglón y nos queda esta matriz nada más
ok el determinante de menos 2 2
así es que después de buscar mucho
tiempo cuál color poner pues me decidí
por este es que todos los demás se
parecen mucho bueno ni modo ok entonces
en esta entrada en lograr este 4 vamos a
poner el determinante de lo que nos
quede de tachar esta fila y esta columna
o sea el determinante de la matriz menos
1 2 2 y 1 ok entonces menos 1 2 2 y 1
finalmente en esta entrada el
determinante de menos 1 - 2 2 1
- 1 - 2 2 1
muy bien y lo que tenemos que hacer es
calcular cada uno de estos determinantes
para que nos quede tal cual la matriz de
menores como tiene que ir con puros
números ok entonces vamos a calcular
cada uno de estos determinantes esta
matriz de menores es igual a y bueno en
realidad no tenía yo que sea una matriz
está en grande porque a final de cuentas
vamos a necesitar menos espacio pero
pues de ánimo ya lo dije sí ok entonces
primera entrada la entrada 11 de nuestra
matriz de menores saquemos este
determinante y como hacemos eso pues
este determinante simplemente es 1 por 5
menos 1 por 4 ok que a final de cuentas
es 5 menos 4 que es uno aquí es donde
uno se puede equivocar muy fácilmente
haciendo cuentas pero bueno aquí
entonces va un 1
ahora vamos con esta entrada su
determinante es 2 x 5 10 menos 1 por 3 o
sea menos 310 menos 3 esto es 7 ahora
vamos con este 2 por 48 menos 1 por 38
menos 3
esos son 55 y pasemos a este menos 2 por
5 eso es menos 10 y luego menos dos por
cuatro
esos ocho o sea menos diez menos ocho
eso es menos diez más menos ocho o sea
menos dieciocho menos 18
ok ahora vamos con este menos uno por
cinco eso es menos cinco menos dos por
tres
o sea que tenemos menos cinco menos seis
o sea menos 11 menos 11 menos 1 por 4
menos 4
2 - 2 x 3 eso es menos menos 6 o sea
menos 4 - menos 6 menos 46 o sea 2
y finalmente nuestra última fila ya me
lo vamos a terminar menos 2 x 1 - 2 - 2
x 1 o sea menos 2 - 2 eso es menos 4
menos 4 y ahora menos uno por uno menos
uno menos dos por 2 4 o sea menos uno
menos cuatro menos cinco menos cinco y
finalmente con este color que no está
tan bien porque no se ve bien menos uno
por uno eso es menos uno y luego menos
menos dos por dos o sea menos dos por
dos es menos cuatro y aquí tenemos menos
uno menos menos cuatro o sea menos uno
más cuatro y esos son tres
muy bien esta es nuestra verdadera
matriz de menores
y para encontrar la inversa de esta
matriz ya nada más nos faltan unos
poquitos pasos
el primero de ellos es muy importante y
es que hay que cambiarle los signos a
esta matriz de menores ok y para eso
vamos a usar una matriz que se parece al
de un tablero de ajedrez ok que
empezamos en un más después va como esto
es una matriz de tres por tres nada más
vamos a hacerla de tres por tres ok y
después de un más va a un menos y
después otra vez un más y por aquí como
aquí tenemos un más pues aquí tienen que
haber un menos
- más menos más se nota porque digo que
se parece a un tablero de ajedrez no y
entonces a las entradas que tengan un
menos vamos a multiplicar las x menos 1
ok y ya con eso vamos a obtener nuestra
matriz de cofactores matriz de
cofactores
ok y para obtener esta matriz de
cofactores lo que hacemos es tomar esta
otra matriz la matriz de menores y
multiplicar las x menos 1 cuando tenemos
un menos en esta matriz en este tablero
de ajedrez y bueno cuando tiene un más
pues podemos pensar que están
multiplicando por unas 1 que no le hace
absolutamente nada a la entrada ok
entonces uno por digamos el símbolo de
más es multiplicar uno por uno y eso nos
deja un 1 después 7 por aquí tenemos un
menos o sea tenemos que multiplicar por
menos 1 y eso es menos 7 menos 7 x 5 y
aquí tenemos un más o sea que dejamos el
5 tal cual como usted menos 18 pero aquí
tenemos un menos entonces qué número va
aquí va un 10 y 8 ahora menos 11 pero
aquí tenemos un símbolo demás entonces
nos va a quedar por aquí menos
2 y aquí tenemos símbolo de menos o sea
que aquí nos queda menos 2 menos cuatro
y tenemos un símbolo de más o sea que
nos queda menos 4 y aquí tenemos un
símbolo de menos o sea que tenemos menos
5 x menos uno o sea un 5 y finalmente un
y tenemos un símbolo de más o sea que
nos queda nada más 3
entonces esta es nuestra matriz de
cofactores entonces ya llevamos un muy
buen tramo del camino de encontrar la
inversa de esta matriz ok ya encontramos
la matriz de cofactores así es que ya lo
único que nos falta es encontrar el
determinante de esta matriz y
multiplicarlo por la transporta de la
matriz de cofactores